سفينه عزيز اكسبريس وصلت للتو الى رصيف
رقم 15 في ميناء جده الاسلامي تحمل هذه
السفينه على متنها 245 حاجا سودانيا وصلت
للتو وهذه تعتبر اول سفينه اذا نتحدث عن
اول دفعه من حجاج السودانيين الذين وصلوا
الى مدينه جده غرب السعوديه وتحديدا الى
ميناء جده الاسلامي لاداء مناسك الحج
عموما هذه السفينه سوف تتبعها ايضا عده
سفن وسوف تكون بشكل مجدول يوم غد وكذلك
الايام المقبله اجمالي عدد الحجاج
السودانيين الذين سوف يعدون مناسك الحج
لهذا العام اكثر من
11,400 حاج سوداني طبعا قبل قليل تم نزول
الرام الخاص بالسفينه وهو رام الذي يعبر
او الذي يربط الرصيف
اي حاج يقدم الى السعوديه سواء عبر المنفذ
البري او البحري او كذلك الجوي الجهه
الاخرى ايضا اداره ميناء جده الاسلامي
وكذلك الاستعدادات من قبل اداره الجمارك
وايضا حرس الحدود هم في انتظار
وصول او اعطاء الاذن حتى نزول حجاج
السودان من هذه السفينه سوف اقترب اكثر
الى هذا الرام وهي وهو الراما كما ذكرت
الرابط بين رصيف من الجده الاسلامي وبين
هذه السفينه هناك عدد من طاقم البحري داخل
هذه السفينه هم في انتظار اعطال اذن وكذلك
فتح هذا الجسر الذي بعد ذلك سيمكن حجاج
السودان من الوصول الى هذه الاراضي وبعد
ذلك يتم نقلهم عبر الحافلات التي سوف
نرصدها الان وهي حافلات مخصصه لهم سوف
تنقلهم الى الصلاه الخاصه لانهاء
اجراءاتهم هناك المرحله الاخيره وهي مرحله
الجوازات السعوديه التي اتمت استعدادها
سواء لحجاج السودان او كذلك الحجاج عامه
وتحديدا في صلاه انهاء اجراءات في ميناء
جده الاسلامي حيث يتم انهاء اجراءات اي
حاجه او من قدم الى السعوديه من اجل مناسك
الحج خلال اربعين ثانيه بعد ان يتم اي
حاجه دخوله عبر المنافذ البريه والبحريه
والجويه اتمام عمليات التاكد من صحته
وسلامته في الجهه الاخرى ايضا وزاره الصحه
هناك عدد من مركبات الاسعاف المجهزه سوف
ايضا هي موجوده كاجراء احتياطيه وطارق لاي
حالات صحيه قد تحدث لا سمح الله للحجاج
سواء على هذه السفينه او السفن الاخرى او
كذلك المنافذ البريه والجويه التي هي
تعتبر ايضا مزوده بهذه المركبات التقنيه
والمتطوره التي تدفع بها السعوديه في حج
هذا العام مازلنا في هذه اللحظات طبعا
نرصد الاخذ الاذن ها هو الان الجسر او
البوابه الخاصه بالسفينه تفتح الان في
انتظار ايضا اكمال الاجراءات حتى الوصول
الحجاج لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات